when you were with him how is his energy
how's he feeling is he uh uh uh planning
on uh uh every time when i see him speak
and in different events at mar-a-lago or
other places he sounds like he is
ready he's warming up for 20 years you
know we spend a good chunk i think this
probably might surprise people we spent
a good chunk going through a lot of
policy type things and he has a c cpac
speech that's coming up not this weekend
but next weekend so we talked through
some of the themes different things he's
going to hit on we talk through
endorsements some people he's endorsing
not going to endorse he started rolling
a bunch of those out last night earlier
uh this morning but i think
the the seriousness and the focus that
he has right now what's going on with
russia and ukraine
but then also the even bigger
existential threat which is china
russia and ukraine i don't want to
trivialize it and say that it's just
noise but compared to china and taiwan
it is noise that's the real threat
because china is going to take taiwan
and they'll do in about 10 minutes and
then everyone else in the south china
sea or anywhere else in the indo-pacific
needs to be on high alert i think
ultimately might be proven wrong as i
saw there's some mortar shells fire this
morning
just in ukraine i think putin probably
wants to make sure there's no nato or eu
expansion um he shores up his domestic
political base by kind of rattling the
saber um he
does something where it makes it look
like biden is weak and he's strong and
then he kind of just rides off in the
sunset and then he rattles his saber
somewhere else i think that's probably
what happens with ukraine and russia
but china's a whole different can of
worms
if if you're a betting man you go to las
vegas
and you have the odds to bet on him
running versus not running you're
betting on what
oh he's he'll run he'll run he'll write
he did not use those exact words
um but i mean he talked in pretty uh
specif as far as the desire the
motivation and part of the thing is like
look he's like if you have someone who's
weak in the white house you're going to
get tested by these foreign leaders
they're just going to steamroll you and
it's a i think a lot of times people see
kind of the you know kind of the affable
and some of the you know sometimes
hyperbolic aspect of the president and
they don't necessarily see sometimes the
the concern level he's really concerned
about the direction of the country with
everything happened with immigration and
inflation and all these different issues
going on he's concerned that if someone
like him doesn't get back in there what
the country's going to look like after
not just the next three years but four
years after that so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]